>> Sean: LIVE BREAKING NEWS.
IRANIAN AGGRESSION ACROSS THE
GLOBE.
THE PRESIDENT BLAMED THE
ESCALATING TENSIONS ON THE
OUTRAGEOUS DEAL THAT BIDEN-OBAMA
MADE WITH THE ROGUE STATE,
PROBABLY THE DUMBEST FOREIGN
POLICY DECISION IN THE HISTORY
OF MAN KIND.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WE'RE GOING TO BE SPEAKING
WITH THE U.K. AND THIS ONLY GOES
TO SHOW WHAT I'M SAYING AND
IRAN.
TROUBLE.
NOTHING BUT TROUBLE.
REMEMBER THIS, THE AGREEMENT,
THE RIDICULOUS AGREEMENT MADE BY
PRESIDENT OBAMA EXPIRES IN A
VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
IT WAS A RIDICULOUS AGREEMENT.
IT GOES TO SHOW YOU, I WAS RIGHT
ABOUT IRAN.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Sean: ALSO THE PRESIDENT
CONFIRMED SENATOR RAND PAUL WILL
BE ASSISTING WITH THE
NEGOTIATIONS.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT THAT ONE.
BUT MAYOR RUDY GULIANI, THE
PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEY, I HAVE
SOURCES THAT I KNOW ARE SOURCES
THAT YOU KNOW WELL.
AND I KNOW YOU HAVE BEEN TOLD
WHAT I HAVE BEEN TOLD.
WE KNOW EXACTLY WHICH NUCLEAR
SITES ARE THE MOST DANGEROUS AND
WE KNOW THE PLANS HAVE BEEN LONG
DRAWN UP TO TAKE THEM OUT.
I HAVE BEEN TOLD AND I THINK YOU
HAVE BEEN TOLD MR. MAYOR AND
FEEL FREE TO GO AS FAR AS YOU
WANT TO GO WITH THIS THAT IT IS
BEYOND DOABLE AND IT WILL HAPPEN
IF THIS CONTINUES.
>> WELL, I HAVE BENEFIT OF
HAVING BEEN IN ALBANIA FOR FOUR
DAYS IN A CONFERENCE IN WHICH WE
HAD 50 NATIONS REPRESENTED,
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS OF OUR
MILITARY INCLUDING SEVERAL
GENERAL OFFICES, A FOUR-STAR
GENERAL, TWO FOUR-STAR GENERALS.
AND I THINK THE COLONEL WAS
SAYING, COULDN'T WE EFFECTIVELY
TAKE THEM OUT 100%?
MAYBE WE WOULD NEED NUCLEAR
WEAPONS FOR THAT.
WE COULD SET THEM BACK FIVE OR
TEN YEARS.
WE COULD MAKE IT IMPOSSIBLE TO
DEVELOP NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
I'M CONVINCED THERE WILL BE A
REGIME CHANGE THERE.
IT COULD HAPPEN THIS YEAR OR
NEXT YEAR.
THE OTHER THING THAT IS
UNDERESTIMATED AND I SAW VIDEO
EVIDENCE OF THIS AND A COUPLE
INTERVIEWS TO SHOW YOU, THE
PROTESTS IN IRAN ARE VERY
SIGNIFICANT.
VERY SIGNIFICANT.
>> Sean: THAT'S FOR REAL.
>> I SAW THE VIDEO EVIDENCE OF
THOUSANDS IN THE STREET.
TAXI DRIVERS, POLITICAL
PROTESTS, ALL THE TEACHERS IN
IRAN WENT ON STRIKE AND CARRYING
POSTERS "DOWN WITH THE
AYATOLLAH."
THAT'S IN RISK OF THEIR LIVES.
DOWN WITH ROUHANI.
THEY'RE CHANTING SUPPORT FOR THE
PEOPLE AND THE COALITION
GOVERNMENT.
THIS IS FACT.
YOU CAN SEE IT.
YOU ALSO SEE SIGNS, I SAW
SEVERAL SIGNS OF MEN SELLING
THEIR KIDNEYS FOR $500 IN ORDER
TO FEED THEIR FAMILIES.
SO THEY'RE INNING IS
SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFICULT TROUBLE.
WE COULD DO SERIOUS DAMAGE TO
ALL OF THEIR NUCLEAR FACILITIES.
WE TAKE SOME OUT, SET THE OTHERS
BACK FIVE OR TEN YEARS.
WE SHOULD TAKE OUT THEIR NAVAL
CAPACITY SO THEY STOP SCREWING
AROUND WITH THE STRAITS OF
HORMUZ.
THE U.K. SHOULD HELP US WITH
THAT.
THEY SHOULD RESIGN FROM NATO IF
THEY DON'T.
>> YOU KNOW THERESA MAY IS WEAK.
LET'S BE HONEST HERE.
>> WHEN THE COLONEL SAID BEFORE
WE HAVE TO GET ALLIES.
FORGET ABOUT FRANCE AND GERMANY.
THEY'RE DOING BUSINESS WITH
IRAN.
I RAN'S REGIME HAS BEEN IN POWER
FOR 40 YEARS.
THEY HAVE COMMITTED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF CRIMES AGAINST
HUMANITY.
SLAUGHTERING PEOPLE IN THE
STREET.
I HAVE SEEN PICTURES OF 120,000
OF THOSE PEOPLE.
I HAVE A BOOK AT HOME THAT HAS
20,000 OF THEM ALL LISTED AND
COMPLETELY AUTHORITATIVE.
I ALSO CAN TELL YOU IN 1988,
THEY KILLED 30,000 PEOPLE IN TWO
MONTHS AND SINCE ROUHANI HAS
BEEN IN OFFICE, THEY KILLED
ALMOST TWICE AS MANY PEOPLE AS
THE OTHER LEADERS, THIS MAN IS A
MASS MURDERS.
THE CRIMES AGAINST HUMANITY AND
EUROPE GIVES THEM MONEY.
WE GAVE THEM OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS.
THAT BILLION DOLLARS WENT TO
KILL PEOPLE.
OBAMA AND BIDEN SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF THEMSELVES FOR DOING
THAT.
YOU KNOW THE PRESIDENT LONGER
THAN I KNOW THE PRESIDENT.
I WANT YOUR INSIGHT.
THIS IS --
>> Sean: HE IS SERIOUS.
THIS IS MY TAKE.
HE WON'T PUT BOOTS ON THE GROUND
EVER.
IT WON'T BE A PROTRACTED WAR IF
DONALD TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT.
ALSO, YOU KNOW ABOUT THIS
EMERGING COALITION AS I DO.
SOMETHING THAT WAS NEVER
POSSIBLE FIVE YEARS AGO.
THE SAUDIS, THE EGYPTIANS,
THEY'RE WITH US.
SO MY QUESTION TO YOU IS, DO YOU
AGREE WITH ME THAT THE PRESIDENT
WILL STAND BY HIS CAMPAIGN
PROMISE, NO BOOTS ON THE GROUND
BUT IF HE STRIKES IT WILL BE
OVER QUICKLY?
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> I WOULD NOT TEST HIM.
I THINK THAT IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
AND HE'S CAPABLE OF DOING THAT.
AT THIS CONFERENCE, THERE WERE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE SAUDI
ARABIA GOVERNMENT.
THEY HAVE JOINED A COALITION.
THERE'S AN ALTERNATIVE.
THE MEK, THE NCRI, A GROUP OF 50
ORGANIZATIONS IS AN ALTERNATIVE
TO THE GOVERNMENT.
THEY'RE WILLING TO DO THE TOUGH
WORK.
ALL THEY NEED IS OUR SUPPORT.
IF THEY TEST THEM, THEY'LL BE --
THEY'LL BE VERY, VERY -- THEY'RE
GOING TO REGRET IT.
HE COULD TAKE THEM OUT IN
SIGNIFICANT WAYS AND SET THEIR
ECONOMY BACK TEN YEARS.
THEY CAN'T STAND THAT RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: IT'S FUNNY.
MY PRISON GUARD MOTHER USED TO
SAY, YOU'LL RUE THE DAY.
>> JUST LIKE THE GENERAL
AFTER -- JUST LIKE THE ADMIRAL
AFTER THE ATTACK ON PEARL
HARBOR.
HE SAID WE HAVE A WAKENED A
SLEEPING GIANT.
WHAT HAPPENED TO JAPAN?
>> Sean: ISRAEL IS REALLY GOOD
AT THIS.
IRAQ IN THE 80s, THE WORLD
CONDEMNED THEM AND THEY TOOK OUT
SYRIA GOING UNDER THE RADAR.
NOBODY TALKS ABOUT IT.
>> I BASE THIS ON THREE MILITARY
GENERALS THAT I SPOKE TO THAT
KNOW THIS BETTER THAN I DO AND
BETTER THAN THE COLONEL DOES.
WE'RE CAPABLE OF DOING
SIGNIFICANT DAMAGE WITHOUT
NUCLEAR WEAPONS THAT WE CAN SET
THEM BACK, THEIR NUCLEAR
CAPACITY AND ECONOMY TEN YEARS.
>> Sean: WE HAVE MANY SIMILAR
FRIENDS.
I KNOW YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT.
THE PEOPLE I SPEAK TO KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT.